stellt euch vor ihr befindet euch auf
einer expedition mitten im
amazonas-regenwald die letzten tage seid
ihr und euer team immer tiefer ins
unendliche grünen vorgedrungen einen
eurer kameraden muss dir bereits
aufgrund eines schlangenbiss es
zurücklassen
ihr selbst seid nur knapp den klauen
eines jaguars entgangen als sie dort
entlang wandert schießt es euch
plötzlich wie ein blitz ins gedächtnis
war es etwa heute schnellkraft ihr das
handy aus dem vollgepackten rucksack und
kontrolliert eure vermutung im
terminkalender
es besteht kein zweifel flinke finger
eine nachricht der downloads auf die
grüne taste und
verzweifelt ihr das handy gen himmel
doch es bringt nichts die geburtstags
nachrichten eure mutter wird sie niemals
erreichen denn diesen teil der erde wird
das internet niemals erreichen
aber vielleicht wird sich das bald
ändern
[Musik]
ein
spacex will mit starling keinen weltweit
empfangbaren breitband internetanschluss
zur verfügung stellen und das über das
weltall
dazu wurden in den letzten zwei jahren
schon 538 satelliten ins all geschickt
118 davon alleine diesem monat 538 das
ist schon eine menge aber noch lange
nicht alles in den nächsten jahren
sollen es insgesamt 12.000 werden
ein antrag für weitere 30.000 ist
bereits gestellt
die sollen dann dafür sorgen dass man
überall auf der welt die möglichkeit hat
mit einer latenz von nur 20
millisekunden im internet zu surfen und
das ist auch der große vorteil gegenüber
der konkurrenz ein satellitengestütztes
internet gibt es schon lange nur weil
die latenz also die verzögerung von uns
zu einem server und zurück bis er um
einiges höher
dadurch war es für viele eigentlich kaum
zu gebrauchen bereits im juni soll eine
interne beta von star link getestet
werden
bis oktober sollen dann die ersten
kunden im norden amerikas auf das
angebot zugreifen können und bis ende
2021 soll s darling dann auch für den
rest der welt verfügbar sein
space experiment stahleck als eigener
internet anbieter auftreten empfangbar
soll das internet durch sogenannte ist
darling terminals seien die sich
automatisch mit den satelliten über
unseren köpfen verbinden wie die
verbindung mit den satelliten
funktioniert das erzähle ich euch gleich
noch mal etwas genauer das terminal an
sich soll jedenfalls so einfach zu
bedienen sein dass man keine experten
zur installation benötigt ok klingt
tatsächlich gar nicht so schwierig und
gerade das macht das potenzial von star
link aus ohne dass millionen kilometer
neue kabel verlegt werden müssten kämen
mit einem schlag milliarden menschen an
schnelles internet
das würde viele teile der welt in ein
neues digitales zeitalter katapultieren
auch das transportwesen kann in zukunft
sehr von den neuen möglichkeiten
profitieren gutes internet jederzeit und
an jedem ort das klingt fast so als wir
das genau dafür gemacht dass starling
terminal kann einfach in oder auf
fahrzeugen schiffen und flugzeugen
verbaut werden
aktuell sind zum beispiel die autos von
tesla für ihre internetverbindung noch
oft gängige mobilfunkmasten angewiesen
in zukunft sollen informationen über
staus unfälle oder wetterbedingungen in
echtzeit mit anderen autos geteilt
werden
da kann eine durchgängige
internetverbindung von großem vorteil
sein
mit hilfe von star league wäre das dann
auch in den abgelegensten gebieten
möglich spacex betreibt also einen
riesigen aufwand um uns überall
schnelles internet zu bringen
aber damit sind auch bestimmt große
kosten verbunden was haben also ihre
maske und space extra von darüber
erzählen euch jetzt die jungs von
simplizissimus etwas mehr
neben den 200 dollar für das terminal
soll es eine monatliche gebühr geben es
wird vermutet dass diese bei zirka 80
dollar pro monat liegen wird bei
millionen von potenziellen nutzern gehen
die gewinne schnell in die milliarden
alleine die versorgung abgelegene orte
sollst basics bis zu 50 milliarden
dollar pro jahr einbringen
gleichzeitig werden die kosten für die
installation und instandhaltung im
weltraum immer günstiger mit mehr
satelliten könnte dass darling internet
in zukunft auch dicht besiedelte städte
erobern
der markt der star link und elon musk
vermutlich bald offen steht ist
grenzenlos und extrem profitabel
auf dem kanal von simplicissimus ist
parallel zu diesem video hier ein video
über die gefahren von starling online
gegangen die jungen sprechen da zum
beispiel mit experten über die
sichtbarkeit der satelliten auf
astronomischen aufnahmen und was für
moralische fragen sich durch die neuen
möglichkeiten von starling ergeben
schaut euch auf jeden fall an die jungs
machen sich alle videos also falls den
kanal noch nicht abonniert habt da kann
ich euch auch das nur empfehlen
aber zurück zum thema denn nicht nur für
die forschung stellt darling kein
problem da richtig gefährlich kann es
dann werden wenn es im vollgepackten
orbit zu einem zusammenstoß kommt das
wäre am 2
september 2009 10 fast der fall gewesen
beinahe wäre ein star link satellit mit
einem esa satelliten kollidiert
das war das erste mal dass die esa ein
manöver zur kollisionsvermeidung
durchführen musste was bei so einem
zusammenstoß passieren kann zeigte sich
damals stießen ein amerikanischer
kommunikationssatellit und ein
russischer aufklärungssatelliten etwa
800 kilometern höhe zusammen beide
satelliten wurden komplett zerstört
bis heute muss es regelmäßig
ausweichmanöver fliegen um nicht von den
über 100.000 trümmerteilen getroffen zu
werden
doch was noch viel gefährlicher ist ist
das was daraus folgen kann man spricht
hier vom sogenannten kessler syndrom
der effekte wurde schon 1978 vom nasa
experte donald kessler beschrieben
er besagt dass es ab einer gewissen zahl
an objekten im labor wird also den
erdnahen orbit unvermeidbar zu
kollisionen kommen wird die trümmerteile
dieser kollision erzeugen dann jeweils
immer mehr zusammenstöße mit anderen
objekten und damit noch mehr trüber das
führt dann im schlimmsten fall dazu dass
die raumfahrt für viele generationen
unmöglich wird
es würden einfach keine raketen mehr
durch das trümmerfeld kommen
und als ob das noch nicht schlimm genug
wäre fallen alle technologien die auf
dem satelliten basieren einfach aus also
gps satelliten internet und noch einiges
mehr
das risiko einer kettenreaktion würde
durch jeden neuen satelliten im all
größer am ende des videos geht es darum
noch mal etwas genauer zum beispiel was
getan werden müsste um die probleme wie
das kessler syndrom zu verhindern und
vor allem auch welche verantwortung ist
bei sex dabei trägt aber wie will spacex
ist überhaupt schaffen so viele
satelliten ins all zu bringen ich meine
240.000 satelliten ist schon eine
hausnummer
praktischerweise können die satelliten
einfach mit den eigenen
wiederverwendbaren feld hinein raketen
in den orbit geschossen werden
es ist sogar möglich die satelliten bei
anderen missionen einfach mit
einzupacken
wer noch platz übrig ist damit es beim
sex die firma die mit abstand am
günstigsten fracht ins all bringen kann
und hat deshalb jetzt schon deutlich
mehr satelliten im orbit als die
konkurrenz ist eine rakete erstmal in
richtung all gestartet dann fliegt sie
bis auf eine bestimmte höhe um die
satelliten dort abzuwerfen
da sind in der regel zwischen 200 und
300 kilometern
die satelliten schweben dann wie ein
paket durch soll innerhalb der nächsten
stunden beginnen sie sich langsam etwas
voneinander zu entfernen und fahren ihre
solarzellen aus danach braucht es ein
paar tage oder wochen bis sich die
satelliten weiter voneinander entfernt
haben
dazu benutzten sie die eingebauten mit
krypton betriebenen jungen triebwerke
was tatsächlich ziemlich cool klingt sie
begeben sich dann auf einen ihrer
operativen orbit zum beispiel auf die
höhe von knapp 550 kilometern und werden
dann teil der starling konstellation
die eingebauten triebwerke helfen den
satelliten nicht nur auf dieser höhe zu
kommen sondern auch objekten in ihrer
flugbahn auszuweichen und sind die
satelliten am ende ihrer laufzeit
angekommen dann bewegen sie sich selbst
wieder in richtung erde wo sie dann in
der atmosphäre verglühen
geplant ist dass die satelliten für etwa
drei bis vier jahre um die erde kreisen
bis sie dann durch neue satelliten
ausgetauscht werden
jeder satellit besitzt insgesamt vier
sogenannte phased array antennen die
laut spacex einen enormen durchsatz an
informationen ermöglichen damit
kommunizieren die satelliten mit den
terminals auf der erde
aber das ist noch nicht alles auch
untereinander sollen die satelliten
reden können und zwar über laser wie
schon gesagt hat da lag einige vorteile
gegenüber der klassischen
internetverbindung per kabel sind die
daten von unserem terminal an einen
satelliten über unseren köpfen
weitergegeben worden
dann findet das signal in wenigen
millisekunden eine verbindung über
mehrere andere satelliten bis es am ziel
terminal angekommen ist
diese verknüpfungen werden durch das
umfassende streckennetz im grunde
genommen von überall möglich sein
viele der satelliten werden im low earth
orbit von nur knapp 500 kilometern
fliegen
dadurch soll es möglich sein die geringe
latenz von etwa 20 millisekunden zu
erreichen
und auch wenn die finale bandbreite also
der datendurchsatz noch schwer zu
definieren ist soll der angeblich
ausreichen um problemlos hochauflösende
filme zu streamen insgesamt sollen
übrigens schon 400 satelliten reichen
damit die konstellation das erste mal
teilweise betriebsfähig ist das sollte
also jetzt schon der fall sein und schon
bei 800 satelliten soll dann eine
signifikante betriebsfähigkeit erreicht
sein
was auch immer das heißt doch selbst
wenn das system voll funktionsfähig ist
und die satelliten mit laser
untereinander kommunizieren können will
space ex nicht den gesamten
telekommunikationsmarkt übernehmen maske
selbst hatte auf der satellite 2020 im
märz versichert das ist darling keine
bedrohung für die klassischen
internetanbieter darstellen soll s
darling würde insgesamt darauf abzielen
sich um die schwer erreichbaren kunden
in abgelegenen gebieten zu kümmern
damit würde man der konkurrenz sogar
einen gefallen tun da genau diese
wenigen kunden den meisten aufwand und
damit höhere kosten bedeuten und für
starling ist ja theoretisch jeder ort
gleich gut erreichbar
sobald der amazonas-regenwald der grund
für diese einschränkung ist dabei aber
wahrscheinlich nicht das wohlwollen
gegenüber der konkurrenz
vielmehr wird s darling in dicht
besiedelten gebieten schnell an seine
grenzen stoßen die bandbreite pro
satellit ist einfach noch nicht groß
genug um viele anfragen gleichzeitig zu
verarbeiten
man werde trotzdem eine kleinere zahl an
kunden den großstädten erreichen aber am
besten funktioniere das system eher ein
spärlich besiedelten gebieten
natürlich kann auch dieses problem mit
genug zeit gelöst werden
theoretisch wäre die weiterentwicklung
der einzelnen satelliten denkbar oder
wir schießen einfach noch mehr
satelliten ins all
aber damit wären wir wieder bei der krux
der sache angekommen sollte es eine
maximale anzahl an satelliten in unserer
erdumlaufbahn geben
und wer entscheidet über die satelliten
die bis dahin noch starten können es mag
ja sein dass kay sex eine staat
erlaubnis für tausende satelliten von
einer amerikanischen behörde erhalten
hat aber am ende fliegen die satelliten
über alle länder und kein anderes land
hat spacex erlaubt auch nur einen
einzigen satelliten ins all zu schießen
jetzt werden erst 12.000 oder sogar
42.000 hinzu kommt dass basics nicht das
einzige unternehmen ist das größere elio
satelliten konstellationen aufbauen will
das unternehmen web aus großbritannien
hat bereits 74 satelliten ins all
geschickt bevor es im märz 2020 pleite
ging
auch facebook hat pläne lässt es aber
erstmal langsam angehen und startet das
projekt china mit dem test einzelner
satelliten
amazon hingegen will für das projekt
keeper noch mal über 3000 satelliten ins
all bringen
und auch der chinesische autobauer geely
plant für seine ehrliche konstellation
angeblich mit bis zu 509 satelliten pro
jahr
zum vergleich stand märz 2020 befanden
sich ohne die satelliten von spacex nur
etwa 2300 im orbit
das bedeutet alleine ist der link wird
diese zahl mehr als versechsfachen
oder vielleicht sogar für 18 fachen wenn
die anderen 30.000 satelliten bewilligt
werden
das risiko eines kessler syndroms wird
also immer größer und um das schlimmste
zu verhindern wird es in zukunft wichtig
seien einheitliche regelungen über
starts und flugrouten zu finden wie es
aktuell schon in der luftfahrt gemacht
wird theoretisch müsste auch jeder
satellit automatisch in der lage sein
die position anderer satelliten zu
erkennen und durch automatisierte
systeme eigenständig seinen kurs
anzupassen
und es wird wahrscheinlich kein weg
darum herum führen die entsorgung von
bereits bestehenden weltraummüll und um
die erde voranzutreiben
ich habe mir gerne mal in die kommentare
wenn ihr dazu ein video von mir sehen
wollte vielleicht sollten wir uns
weniger darüber unterhalten wie schnell
jetzt das internet von star link wird
und mehr darüber wie wir verhindern
können dass uns die gesamte raumfahrt in
den nächsten jahrzehnten um die ohren
fliegt dieses video ist eine
zusammenarbeit mit simplizissimus wenn
jetzt noch mehr über die negativen
auswirkungen der vielen satelliten auf
die astronomie und auch mögliche soziale
probleme erfahren wollt dann schaut euch
gerne das video von den beiden hier an
und vergesst nicht den kanal zu
abonnieren
was sie wahrscheinlich sowieso schon
getan hat und natürlich würde mich auch
eure meinung interessieren was haltet
ihr von den plänen
und wie steht ihr zu den risiken lassen
uns gerne unten in den kommentaren
diskutieren ansonsten vielen dank fürs
zuschauern und bleibt immer neugierig
patrick und ich fliege zu spielen wird
ließ
[Musik]